each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available great so um so let's go ahead
and get started for the next session um
where uh so this session is on code and
uh program model
and we're happy to have kind of two
speakers one who's coming more from a PL
software engineering perspective and
then another one who's coming more from
a machine learning perspective um so the
first speaker is going to be um Earl bar
so uh he's a a rare bird in the sense
that um he's been working um um both in
the programming language and the
software engineering communities and
this is something from the outside I
didn't um realize that it's actually
unusual to be able to do work that's
considered significant in both
communities um Earl was one of the uh
was kind of involved in the kind of
early days of the naturalist research he
was on the original um some of the
original papers on that and he and I
have also had uh uh a kind of very
fruitful collaboration about uh applying
engram language models and um one thing
is uh that I noticed was uh uh kind of
also uh very impressive is that when I
went through his Publications list there
seemed to be no fewer than five uh best
paper Awards in the past 10 years which
uh um which is very nice so so thank you
Earl thanks Charles um the brief that I
was given by Charles and Chen for this
was to uh um tell the the ML and NLP
people in the in the in the room about
uh problems that might be um
particularly interesting to you areas
that um where your your your techniques
and approaches might be particularly
fruitful uh I'm I'm um I'm I'm I'm based
in London and uh I'm this 10:30 at night
for me and I've gotten about four hours
of sleep for the last two nights so I'm
um I feel like I'm underwater right now
so uh given that that I've cast this
talk toward the the the ml guys so
fellow software Engineers help me out if
I have a brain freeze help me help me
explain these slides okay so um a core
seminal problem in software engineering
is inferring intent
uh because intent is more fundamental
than semantics if we know what the
intent is we can we we can constrain and
trap the semantics problem and so hidden
behind a blizzard of terminology that
you've been exposed to in the you know
in the talks today and yesterday and in
your foray into the the software
engineering literature is a a search for
for
intent so when you at in the beginning
of a project uh you have you ideally you
have requirements and you have a code
base and uh so this the the traceability
problem which you've heard a lot about
in pieces today Jane and Dennis is um
finding this link linking the
requirements to the code base uh and and
here's a particular example you know
class uh class implements requirements
one two and three so that's some class
here in the code base and if I the
reason um this problem is so important
is because um when we when we have
knowledge of the requirements we can we
can know things like what some code is
intended to do and if we know what it's
intended to do we can build tools to
check whether it it in fact does that we
can try to verify which is uh a holy
grail of sofware engineering
verification validation of the
correctness of a program so and it and
um it can also prioritize uh development
uh and you know which bug to fix uh it's
it's well known that most most large
projects have uh thousands or uh even
tens of thousands of of open unfixed
bugs and what that means is that's
that's because um of finite resources we
have finite resources to fix bugs and so
we need to uh allocate our those finite
resources efficiently effectively and if
we knew which requirements were uh bound
to which bugs we could make that make
those decisions more effectively and um
requirements constrain the space of code
and variance in properties when we know
uh code and variance when we know
properties of the code we can we can
check we can whether they hold or not uh
and they're they're useful for these
task uh code understanding and
verification and others am I missing
software Engineers am I missing an
important one
here sorry TR as related to traceability
for this particular for this edge
here good I mean there's all sorts of
other things but I'll talk a little bit
about that when it's my talk but about
safety analysis and compliance
verification I hope you will jump into
this talk if if it if it becomes um if
you see a point where that where it's
better um makes more sense okay so a
codebase is um I I oversimplified a
moment ago a codebase is a test suite
and
code um and I've I've written the test
Suite here on the requirements side
because often a test Suite is informed
by the requirements it it captures um
some under approximation of them and I
note that although I haven't made a link
here we even even this link between a
test suite and the codebase is
problematic we we often don't know for a
given um test case what it's intended to
test what what it's what it's supposed
to test so um and you might think that
uh if you're the ml people might think
that that's strange or maybe you know
some of you might it's mediate why it's
not strange but you might think I just
look at the path but if you look at um a
test case that uh is testing the windows
codebase for instance almost say you
have a test case that's testing um the
key Integrity of a database it needs to
uh Traverse the file system the uh of
the operating system it has to check it
traverses the code that opens files and
closes files in the in the operating
system it's not intending to test those
but it needs to Traverse them in order
to get to the point to test the database
system and so uh knowing which pieces
which subp parts of the path that it
Traves that it is intended to test um is
is non
non-trivial and uh a codebase is just a
checkout it's just a snapshot of a
version history and uh this this uh
conglomeration here is uh a software
repository as in mining software
repositories in MSR sense uh aka the
salt mines where we software Engineers
when we're doing mining this is where we
go and uh chip away at uh at the
features and properties in order to um
correlate features of this of this data
with software engineering outcomes of
Interest
but but these things don't just happen
in a vacuum requirements come from
somewhere and the and the source is
stakeholders and uh traceability
includes this Edge as well it's this um
these are called um prere requirements
and and post uh and according to finlin
at all uh more more problems more uh
problems in projects happen here
primordially uh and it'd be really great
again if we could infer these infer this
Edge all of these edges are all of these
relations are are problematic we they
were we our our requirements are partial
and the links between our requirements
and our different artifacts are partial
and and
noisy and it's more complicated than
that we have uh all of this additional
data we have issue trackers uh mailing
lists documentation and logs uh and
we've been talking about that today and
yesterday so roswan you were you worked
on this link um you were using
information retrieval to connect issue
trackers with with the code base here
not with the version history because you
weren't looking at commits but you were
looking at files inside the current
checked out version am I is did I
understand that correctly actually for
every bug report we uh created a
snapshot of the source code that was uh
in place when the bug was submitted so
you were looking you were making the
connection to the version history then
yes yeah
um so um Chris who's uh in into his
laptop right now um he he did a lot of
work right here on on inferring this
this Arc uh you know and and also this
Arc um help me out uh who else's um
particularly has focused on particular
arcs
here yeah nagapon here um
T has been
everywhere what what were you gonna say
Jane I a lot of the work I'm going to
documentation I think that Andy did
right with Julio and Jonathan mtic yeah
and and also on documentation um marttin
rubia and Peter Rigby are currently
doing things here
um so then software uh mining software
repositories has evolved from this core
to you know has has been expanding uh
to because uh we're data hungry just as
machine learning is data hungry we were
trying to gather more data that we can
leverage to solve our problems and again
I want to emphasize we're uh this this
this is all noisy data we're missing
edges are the edges that we infer and
that we have documented are
erronous and
uh mining includes requirement documents
when we have them and it even includes
stakeholders uh uh we there was um at IC
I forget when um we put some developers
into nmri machine and gave them some
problems uh which one was that Prem
which which ex was that the was that
2014 that was
yeah
2014 so what this talk about I didn't
realize this until earlier today but
this this talk is about the fact that
Jane and Dennis's work on Trace lab they
they need your help they need um they
because I I think Jane look there are
lots of open problems here still there's
lots of different tools and although
you've you've brought a lot of Weaponry
to Bear there's there's more to be done
here and there's more that needs to be
done and um so yeah so let's let's help
her out let's help out um Trace
lab he's on the project too oh I didn't
I didn't I didn't connect that you were
you were an integral member also
yeah okay so
um this is this is where um I'm going
out on a limb I'm I'm suggesting uh
maybe uh a a related an ml technique or
tool that might be useful here uh
relation extraction so um as I
understand it this extracts entities in
their relation from unstructured textt
so this is where Dana I don't see Dana
there you are um where your work comes
into play and where you know I hope that
this picture that I've shown could give
you you you asked where where where
could this be useful well you can
recover these links and when you recover
these links you can give us uh features
that we can use to build tools that can
check whether they hold or
not um so and and the other thing that I
want to the other point I want to make
that that that why this might be
particularly interesting to to the
machine learning NLP Community is that
um all of this data is relatively
structured uh source code is structured
requirement documents are uh usually in
semi-formal English some kind of
subdialect of English or they can even
be formal uh or they can be some mix of
formal uh semi-structured and notes on
the back of a napkin but they but
they're more structured than than just
text on the web arbitrary text on the
web and and that and that structure and
those constraints might simplify the
problem might be able to be leveraged to
improve the performance on on some
Dimension uh like in terms of uh it the
accuracy the its resistance to noise or
speed okay so uh the problem that we
software engineering have is that uh
much as requirements are great and we
would like to have them we often don't
have them many projects simply we we
don't have requirements at all uh I
worked on Wall Street and uh you know I
worked for a startup and uh we didn't we
didn't we didn't do requirements at all
we we everything was verbal and uh it
was all about meeting deadlines uh it
was a very ad hoc uh development model
and I think the the dirty secret of
industry is even given the agile rage
right now is it's mostly ad hoc and so
we just have we don't really have
requirements and if we if if it were
easier to I think if it were easier to
maintain to discover and maintain these
links it would make it cheaper and also
more worthwhile to save this data Jane
so I just like to make one comment there
because I think in like software
engineering projects they tend to not
have often not have requirements but
when you get into the systems and
engering World they almost always have
requirements written down so it's kind
of the two sides of it so Jane just
talked about a domain uh that I'm not
familiar with that I where I didn't work
um uh so but but that that's that's also
interesting there there that means that
there are some domains where you you can
rely on this existing uh and others
where it's it it is a problem to has to
be discovered when when this doesn't
exist what we can do is we can
uh think about um uh another way of uh
recording and capturing programmer
intent which is programming by contract
and and in this case we don't we don't
have the requirements written in a form
where uh stakeholders can understand
them necessarily we have them in a much
more much lower level in the form of
specifications embedded in the code so
this is a a little fragment of a uh a a
language that I admire um called Daphne
um here from Microsoft research Redmond
uh a language that supports a designed
by or by contract note the TM there uh
uh yeah and uh so this is a
precondition
um uh this is a precondition that says
um this function expects this to hold on
that parameter and this is the post
condition which says that what the the
guarantee is that this this will hold on
X when when the when it
computes question about your slide your
your Lamentations about the absence of
requirements um is this becoming more of
a problem or less of a problem as people
are doing this kind of agile devops kind
of stuff so there's um it is true that
agile means that there's um requirements
manifest in the agile model as story
points and they are being written down
but they're written down in a in a very
vague very tur um almost slogan style
way uh almost as like labeling for um a
collection of um you know U What in in
um I'm having a brain Fate on the word
in a in a movie when they have a a
storyboard like almost in a storyboard
style um so they're even less useful um
to my mind than semi-formal English
requirements in a in a like a DARPA uh
Abram uh in the devops context there's a
lot of these files kicking around
requirements.txt
and a lot of the times they're they
really should be renamed to dependencies
but often times they're basically how to
build the system that's going to host
your software so in a devops context
requirements is often times how to build
the environment for the uninitiated can
you tell us what devops means uh devops
is when you ask your programmer to be
aist admin at the same time and
basically deploy to the cloud for the
most part so so devops is also sometimes
continuous deployment so basically when
you have a build infrastructure that set
ups that way after every commit you have
really good automated tests and you're
always running the latest version so
GitHub is very well known for doing this
so they they say we don't have releases
we don't have a deploy button we have
commits and basically after every single
commit that's done to their code base
it's up there running on the site and
the emology is uh devops is developer
operator something like system operator
but in in in between you might still
have a system
in sorry no um so the cool thing about
uh design by contract is that you can uh
if you if if the program is fully a um
annotated with these annotations you can
mechanically uh verify it you can prove
properties of it
uh the the fly in the ointment here is
uh loop and variance Loop and variance
are are a very hard problem and um
recently there's been um there's really
interesting paper from 2013 by Aken and
and his co-authors that uses um probably
approximately
correct um to uh make good progress on
this so uh let's let's put this aside
for a moment and let's consider simple
assertions
so simple assertions are are like this
one uh taken from H forget where I got
this anyway some language it's either
JavaScript or Java and the the point is
that it it this is the the assert
construct so this isn't a language where
we we don't have preconditions and
postconditions we just have this assert
construct and just having um a code uh
that's annotated with a couple of these
allow me to um verify something
properties of it at least locally I can
now I can make progress toward um
validating and verifying that that
program the the problem is that even for
these lightweight applications and this
is even more true for design by contract
is the the tax man cometh so uh there's
the problem of the context switch uh if
you've if you've actually developed in
um a uh design by contract context uh uh
it it it's a it's a different mode of
thinking way do you agree with that I
mean you've you've you know you're from
um Bertrand Meyer's
group yeah it's not an easy shift to
think to make is it I mean you're you're
thinking imperatively you're thinking
about the flow of of values and then you
think in this declarative um Universal
universally Quantified in this
Quantified
way you certainly need a bit of training
but it is not that difficult once you're
up up with training is very natural to
write down at least simple so are you
denying that there's not so I I claim
there's a context switch even when
you're you're highly trained that you it
is a different mode of
thinking it becomes very natural so you
don't do this content switch at all the
time and also but did you find yourself
going in phases between them did you
spend part of your time uh writing the
the code and then focusing on The
annotation or do you you oscillate
between them well I I find myself
writing contract first before program
and I do this even if I program python
andc I think it's kind of it's kind of
it helps a lot if you're used to doing
it that way then it's very natural for
you I guess if you're not used to it
it's not so easy and the tax is
something that you you pay the tax and
you get a lot of B debugging becomes
much more natural and faster but this is
almost an ideological debate because um
even conservatives here in the US you
know they get a lot of benefit you know
we have uh Public Safety Interstate
freeways and so on but they still don't
want to pay tax um I I think we should
all you know it sounds to me like we
would all benefit from this cool ID
think it so so regardless
of uh regardless of of how heavy
actually the tax is and and what the
benefits are exactly so um you know
taking way comments into into account
I've I've had personally I've had a
little more I felt a little bit more
fleeced by it but I haven't spent as
much time as as as you have uh doing it
um developers don't write annotations
that much they they avoid it they don't
do it in practice they they've been they
voted with their feet uh and they you
know they don't use these languages very
much eiffel's been around for um more
than two decades and it it it's not it
hasn't had much industrial traction
like Mike and his team at you published
paper I think last year or two years ago
on studying Co contracts being used in
open source projects indeed like a lot
of those project actually using Co
contract tend to write preconditions
which are I mean much simpler for you to
specify and but still post conditions
are very difficult to specify I mean our
take is that it's
as you you hinted on to complicate
enumerate Universal Property in the end
of the meas body uh we are pushing on
paret unit testing basically invented
2005 at Microsoft research and naturally
supported by PEX Now power viiew C 2015
uh that may have some good hope for
uptake in Industry so it's kind of like
scarium based specification it's writing
unit test but you are writing
specifications in when you don't even
expressely realize you are writing
formal
specifications so Lynn tan from
Waterloo judging from comments in a
bunch of BSD systems found that there
were there were contracts in the
comments but none of these are
executable or immediately checkable and
they're sort of handwavy but the
developers would write these little
preconditions right there in the
comments in C programs but the C type
system is not capable of handling any of
that Y and um I worked for as a
professional developer for 10 years
before coming back to Academia and and I
can attest to often in comments before
functions you'd see
preconditions um that was definitely um
so the the challenge here the the the
the thing where ml might um be able to
help us is in suggesting assertions um
you know helping us alleviate The
annotation tax um daon is a dynamic um
it's been mentioned several times uh
yesterday and today it's a dynamic
invariant detector it has a universal
set of um um invariants that are
invariant templates and then it in you
know it uh invalidates or disproves them
at various program points by through
Dynamic executions but those are those
um its invariants these invariant
templates were uh created by erns from
first principles just you know thinking
about it um and it it seems to me that
we might be able to use machine learning
to uh uh learn um uh possible invariants
that are bespoke or tailored for a
particular uh code base and have have
them be ones that are more likely to be
um interesting because the the problem
with daon is it finds many vacuous uh uh
irrelevant uh invariants that are that
are true they you just haven't found a
run that disproves them and even if and
they're they're irrelevant to the the uh
actual behavior of the uh function
or and then another issue is uh so
suggesting what assertions and then
suggesting where to place them where
they're they're in a sense they're
probes they have overhead they probes to
the state space um it might be it there
might be more natural places to put them
than than
others places that like uh dominate um
that are dominators in the control flow
graph for instance and and those are not
obvious to uh human developers
necessarily they're easy to find uh uh
using static analysis but not immediate
to to humans necessarily this is clearly
a place where something that performs
well would be automatically better than
humans because humans don't do that well
right
so sorry can I ask what is dominator in
the control flow of gravity it's a it's
a it means that all paths to um uh a a
node in a in a graph dominates another
node if all pass to this The Descendant
node must pass through the Dominator
okay thanks okay so um what what
developers tend to do especially now in
the age of agile is they write they
write tests that we do have lots of
tests not as many as we'd like and
that's a problem that I'll talk about in
a moment but they do you know Agile
development tenant is you write a test
you run you write the least amount of
code you write code scaffolding
that passes the test or that checks the
test and then you you iterate until you
reach a fix
Point
um and uh so there are two um I'm going
to talk to you about two lines of work
in uh software engineering that exploit
test Suites uh to do something that test
Suites weren't necessarily designed to
do test test Suites are normally
designed to um uh for regression testing
to prevent so they they give you
confidence that you can make changes you
can evolve the the the code without
introducing without breaking existing
functionality uh and these two are
automated program repair and software
transplantation so um automated program
repair it it assumes it requires
something that localizes the bug and
what it does is it synthesizes a past
there many you know the there's a a a
wide variety of different automated
repair techniques that differ in terms
of how they synthesize a fix U but the
goal is to fix uh is to synthesize a fix
that passes the test suite and their
underlying assumption is that a test
Suite built for a given buggy program
variant can can validate uh a patch
program so they're they're in some sense
they're they're saying that this test
case um uh has some inferential power
beyond uh just the the version of the
program for which it was
written
and I I have a a paper this year on
automated software
transplantation uh and the idea is that
you you find a donor program and uh an
organ of interest uh some some code
functionality that you you want to move
and this um this organ of Interest has
different paths to it uh in the in the
donor program and each one of these
paths each vein uh is notable in that it
builds the program State a program state
that this organ expects in order to uh
execute properly so uh using a test
Suite that exercises this organ um I can
um slice out the organ and one of its
veins uh insert it into a host uh where
uh it uh it then can be exercised um
automating the the process of um moving
functionality from one code one code
base to another
and you don't get this for free there
there are three um strong assumptions
that we make one is that the the the
developer must give us the organ entry
point the developer must give us an
organ test suite and the developer must
also specify an imple impl implantation
point where um the free variables of the
organ uh you know can be can be
met um and and so again uh we're using
uh or test Suites under approximate
behavior and so um as with test um
automated program repair the an
assumption of the system is that where
the test Suite is coincidentally
allowing us to um um approximate the
behavior better than uh uh you know that
it gets it has it casts some Shadow
around its uh under
approximation we're relying on some
inferential power here and that the
question is you know that that's not
formal we're we we just built these
tools and they work but we don't
understand exactly you know what what if
any you know what what H how are how are
we ex using how are we exploiting
getting coincidental correctness from
these test Suites um and that the tests
are a bias sample of the program's
Behavior
so a question here is you know can we
infer a program's intended input distrib
distribution so when a program is
actually deployed and in use it sees
inputs that have some probability
distribution um that are different from
those encoded in the test suite and
they're different from say uniformly
using your uniform random testing and so
a question is can can we get at what
what the the field input distribution
might be from the text of the the code
text and from from a test Suite so uh a
possible way to um
accomplish this would be to use uh um
techniques from survey waiting so
surveys have the problem that they they
sample a population and they're and
they're not actually doing that uh
uniformly so the the so you can wait
them to try to correct for
non-uniformity in the in the in the
sampling and it there might be that
there's something we can do here to
reweight a test Suite in order to get it
closer to uh the the um intended input
distribution another possible uh uh
problem related here is it we although I
said that programmers do write um in the
era of Agile development developers do
write test Suites they they still don't
write enough uh of them it would be nice
it it it's it's tedious and difficult um
and so it'd be nice if we could help
them write test Suites and the the
problems with writing it's it's not a
solved problem uh most if you if you
just randomly generate if you just
randomly sample the input domain of a
program most of your test Suites are
going to be useless and
redundant and uh if if you find one
that's not useless and redundant uh you
don't know if the output of the program
is correct this is the the Oracle
problem and it's often um you often see
this problem neglected in discussions of
automated test
generation so
uh my my proposal to the ml Community
here is uh this might be a good place
for active learning it might be that um
we could use uh an active learning
process with the
program um and you know query the the C
the program's uh concrete Behavior to
infer uh likely correct Behavior like a
question that we could ask is can
variable X be null and then uh Not only
would we have um uh uh test
the the queries but we would also have
some uh uh error bar around a likely
possible correct answer uh using so this
this technique might help us uh address
the the Oracle problem okay I've I've
talked about
three for the previous slides um about
10 years ago uh there's a company aa aa
one there their product basically
inspired by by the D
idea uh more or less they are they doing
that basically they infer likely
invariance but with a a much smaller
subset of the invariance normally
produced by dard they they want to deal
with
usability uh and another very important
things they have been mind that these
invariants are not supposed to be
comprehensive they are more like a
triggering starting Pawn for
encouraging this worker to write more
assertions so there's a lot of human
factors into pictures I mean uh I have
this conversation with the co-founders
more than 10 years ago are they still
around uh it was close to bankruptcy
several years back and why do you think
that is T I don't I mean it's a long
story okay we talk about offline but I
mean still a good product okay and and
um if for more content and look at there
I think the ISTA 2007 they have a paper
on the product and and the whole history
of about how they push for inferring
these kind of invariance and and for
getting their products I mean being used
by developers I want to pick up and
amplify something that t said that I I
hope I made when I was talking about
assertions any assertions that we get
would be better than the current
situation so even if we we just get a
handful more that's a handful that we
didn't have that we can
leverage okay um thank
you by shaki I mean there is one problem
might be assertion you have to ensure
those assertions are correct otherwise
you know it will have a I mean magnified
problem I mean then without having an
assertion and I mean we did little bit
testing like if we because the training
set of assertion is so less and if we I
mean somehow automatically generate
assertions gives lot of false positives
at least at current state I mean right
so that's the challenge that I was yeah
that that's the challenge that was
implicit to what I was saying is that
you know we'd have to do it with
sufficient
accuracy and yes um even human region
assertion is are quite commonly
incorrect so we did um review of 20
years of IO assertions when there is a
dispute of a crash whether is assertion
is wrong or implementation is wrong it's
50/50 I see and when it is case St
Solutions around the problem is so much
harder to face exactly I I completely
because developers T to believe on them
and then you know it becomes more and
also it it's Al it's much easier to
propagate to other parts of the system
because they all rely on this solution
to be true
yeah so actually one one project that
mik g had proposed to me uh to try to
collaborate on which I hope we'll do
someday but we haven't started is to
read assertions and read the English
comment that goes with it because that's
one of the places that typically is more
often common at than others I guess and
to actually try to just find if it's
actually lined up yeah so is the code
actually doing what the English says it
should be
doing and as we get into the sort of
semantic parsing talks for those you
that don't know what semantic parsing is
you'll see that one Hallmark there is
doing really compositional so building a
big complex things by putting little
pieces of meaning on each of the words
it's very different than a language
model or something like that that and
that's exactly what you would need to
sort of build those more structured
Asser queries so it's sort of an
interesting place to think about from an
NLP side too hope do you get enough
English text aligned with assertion so I
haven't actually looked at the data but
the feeling was at least for Java you
would um and large repositories because
people tend to do it but I actually
haven't the data so I don't know but it
was an interesting
idea good great so okay let's thank
girl
okay good and uh from coming from a
machine learning perspective we have um
Danny tarlo from Microsoft research so
although in a physical sense he's come a
very long way to be here in some sense
in a logical sense he hasn't really
traveled at all um so he's uh he did his
uh PhD um kind of doing machine learning
and computer vision at the University of
Toronto and he's done a kind of really
wide range of research um ranging from
kind of uh of more methodological work
in approximate inference and graphical
models like um one paper uh was one one
a best paper award from this past nips
and in addition I see kind of computer
vision and some sports statistics uh
paper and um then today he's going to
talk about some really interesting work
that he's done on uh neural language
models for source code all right thank
you um so thanks for the invitation here
and I guess the message for the talk
that I want to give is there's this
class of models that we've been using
when trying to build language models for
code that seem like they strike a really
nice balance of being relatively simple
hopefully that's that's my hardest task
is to convince you that it is simple um
but also useful and flexible in allowing
us to get some of the benefits of neural
networks that we heard about yesterday
in their power and their flexibility but
also giving us the opportunity to put
things that we know about source code
into the models so for example that
there are variables and they have
certain Scopes and they live for some
amount of time and you have a tree
structure um So the plan is to just tell
you about this class of models hopefully
in a way that you all uh agree that
they're
neat um right and I should say uh this
is based on work with Chris Madison
Milos salanus Sandy Gordon and
U okay so the motivation I think we've
talked a lot about this I just want to
reiterate for myself why is it that we
want to build models of source code I
think the general idea is uh we've heard
lots of cases where there's a whole
Space of programs that meet some
requirement but you'd like to return a
natural one maybe you're just interested
in in the probability of code but sort
of my way of thinking about is anytime
that you want to generate code that
people are actually going to look at
then you probably care about generating
code that's natural and that uh obeys
some uh conventions that that you find
in real code and so we'd like to build
models that produce probability
distributions of code that are learned
from real
code yeah what's Auto coding source code
um so if if you are coming up so
something that people like to do in say
computer vision is you take an image you
map it to some code so this is like
semantic hashing came up earlier uh you
have some low dimensional representation
of an image and then you'd like to map
it back to the original image and so
it's this compression technique um and
so if you were thinking about okay how
do I get from my code that I generated
back to my source code uh then you could
imagine a model of source code would be
useful here it's like an eding of source
code into another
space yeah I'm just I I'm saying I think
that probabilistic models of source code
would be useful in that context for
example anywhere that you're sort of
outputting code that's natural
code
I I don't want to spend too much time on
it because it won't come up again but we
can talk
later um okay right so this is what I
said before the message that I want to
convey is when you're trying to build a
model of source code you don't have to
choose between what you know and all the
goodness of neural network life models
okay so there's four basic ideas that I
want to build up from um in thinking
about modeling code um the first one is
going to be very much from natural
language processing looking at parsing
um what are called history based models
of of um tree structures and then I'll
talk about the log by linear neural
language models that we heard some about
yesterday um applied to code and then
I'll talk about some more code specific
issues and then finally I'll show a
couple ways that you can flexibly use
this framework in other
ways okay so let's start with history
based tree models just as a starting
point um when thinking about modeling
code you have this first decision that
you have to make which is what is the
representation what is the base
representation of code and the two
popular ones seem to be either you model
tokens so you take this as just a flat
file you have a sequence of tokens that
you've you have from your lexer uh and
then you want to model this as a
sequence and the other option uh is to
think of code as a tree so you run it
through your parser and then you can get
back a abstract syntax tree and then
what you want to do is is generate these
and so I'm very much going for this this
bottom class okay so we're we're going
to be thinking about generating source
code which is just sort of the leaves is
what what you'll do is you'll generate
this tree and then if you want to read
off the sequence of tokens you can just
Traverse uh the leaves of this tree and
that will give you back exactly your
source
code um okay so tree structures and
thinking about models of tree structures
this has a long history in natural
language processing and thinking about U
parsing so something that people think
about there is we want to generate or
what we'd like to do is we'd like to
take a sentence and produce a parse tree
but a way of thinking about this is
saying I'm going to come up with a
generative model of par trees and then
I'm going to observe some data and try
to infer what the Parry was um so we can
look to natural language processing for
a lot of examples of this um and the key
difference here though is is in source
code it's easier so we have access to a
compiler we can just run it we can get
back our parse trees there's no
ambiguity in the parses we know that the
parse tree exactly fits fits our data so
even though we can look to these these
models it's actually much simpler to
apply them in the source code setting
than it is the natural language setting
or at least at learning time it's easier
to learn these
things um okay so what's kind of the
simplest model of tree that we can think
of let's start with probabilistic
context free grammars so the way this is
going to work is we're going to gener
generate a tree but we're going to do it
um one step at a time where at each step
what we're going to do is we're going to
say we're given a parent node in the
tree and we want to generate a tuple of
children nodes okay so this is going to
be the basic operation that we're
working with just to set some notation
here we're going to use R to represent
the parent node C to represent the child
node do I have a pointer no um and then
this R to C is a production and if you
were to try to learn a probabilistic
context free grammar from observing
trees in your model the sort of the
maximum likelihood estimate would be
this thing on the right where you look
in your data and you say how many times
have I seen a production that had a
parent node R and generated a child node
C and then you would normalize that by
the number of times you saw any
production that started with the parent
node R okay uh and then I'm going to use
this notation a lot throughout so
instead of thinking of it as this ratio
of counts I'd like you to think of it as
there's some parameter B for each
production from R to C and what we're
going to do in order to come up with our
probability is just exponentiate this
number and then divide by all of the
possible children tupal that we might
see so that this is a probability okay
but it's just in this case they're
exactly
equivalent um right so how would this
look if we're trying to generate a
syntax tree corresponding to a program
uh we're going to start with a parent
node here so let's say we happen to just
say we want a four statement then the
first step we're going to generate a
tpol of children and so this this is the
nodes below it that we would we would
see inside our compiler um and then what
we're going to do is we're going to
recurse to the leftmost non-terminal
node here the
initialization uh we're going to decide
it's a single variable
declaration uh that requires a type a
name and an initializer the type is
going to be int the name is going to be
I and on and on and on and we can
generate this tree okay and so oops at
the end of the day we've at the leaves
we've generated the source code and
actually I've I've messed up a little
detail here because I've dropped a few
tokens that should belong in here but
think there there should be the tokens
corresponding to equals and the
semicolon and whatnot just as additional
nodes
here okay um so right this is all well
and good we can go to data we can learn
these types of models just fine they
don't work particularly well they're not
so much different than engram models as
far as my experience is concerned um but
so the the sort of the first neat idea
here is if you're thinking about
generating a tree then in natural
language processing I think they call
these history based models and the idea
is at if what what what you think about
when you're generating this tree is you
have a sequence of decisions to make
okay so you're sort of traversing this
tree that you're creating and at each
point you're making a decision about
what is the next Tuple of children that
I should generate and the observation
here is that it's perfectly fine it
doesn't change anything in this setting
in terms of the complexity of learning
or anything uh to say that my decision
about what child to generate next is not
just going to be a function of what type
of parent I had like it was in the
probabilistic context grammar but it can
be a function of any of the decisions
that I've made in the past okay so when
we're coming here we've generated into I
equals z now we're at the left oper end
and we're trying to decide what should
be the child that we're generating next
what we can do is we can come up with
this I think of it as this big
dictionary where we have features and
values of what's been done so far so you
can say things like okay uh in the tree
what is the history of ancestors above
me um so you know above left oper end is
infix expression that's the first
ancestor and then above that is
expression above that is for statement
you can also say let's look at the past
let's look at the previous tokens this
would be like you would get in an engram
model you can say how deep am I in the
tree you can you you can literally have
any function of the previous tree that
you've generated so far uh and then what
you're allowed to do is before I had
this this just a single number here um
in the numerator so we have this x here
but what it can be is you can have an
arbitrary function of the child uh Tuple
the parent node and the history that
you've seen so far and you can combine
these together to give you a score so
you can think about sort of linear
models or other sorts of models I'll get
into more details about
this um okay so now let's let's add in
this neural component or this log by
linear component so to get here let's
take what I've told you just now and
forget about the tree stuff and let's
just go back to modeling sequences so
let's think about what a log by linear
engram model would look like so this is
what we heard about yesterday um
hopefully you remember these these
neural language models not the recurrent
ones but the ones that came before that
and um
well I guess we could start even with an
engram model so we're we're now saying
that we're generating a tree but there's
only one parent type in the tree and
that's token and then the the children
are just individual tokens of the model
uh so now we want to decide what should
come next below this token well in this
history based model we can say we just
have this dictionary of what the
previous tokens are what the previous
end tokens are and then our function uh
there that's the numerator can be some
arbitrary function of this it could be
the NR counts or it could be um some
sort of embedding based thing and so
that's what I'm going to tell you about
now uh
so I should have had some things appear
okay so this is the this is the work
that you saw yesterday as well this is
about neural network language models uh
and if you go to the paper you'll see a
figure that looks like this it's not too
intimidating I promise um what you have
is you have a neural network at at the
bottom
what you're going to have is the
previous words so in this case you know
in I equals or whatever uh and then what
you're going to do is you're going to
take these words and you're going to map
them to a fixed length Vector so a d
dimensional Vector of real values that
sort of represent the embedding of what
this word means and then what you're
going to do is you're going to
concatenate the representations from the
previous and words together and that's
going to give you this hidden State here
um this is is going to be followed by a
nonlinearity like you find in a neural
network a hyperbolic tangent here and
then there's going to be a matrix U that
transforms the hidden state to be the
size of your output vocabulary so of
something that gives you a score for all
possible tokens that you might have in
your model okay so then this is your y
here at the top it's a big Vector of
length the size of your vocabulary then
you're going to normalize this to be a
probability distribution and that's
going to give you your predictive
distribution hopefully this is just
slightly different notation for what we
heard about yesterday um but what you
can do is you can think about this in
exactly the equation that I showed you
before at the end of the day there's
this normalization over the words in
your vocabulary where the probability of
the I word is some function of I and the
history that you've seen so far and the
history that you've seen so far involves
uh there's also these parameters about
all of these
embeddings and the actual equation looks
something like this and I think it's
worth looking at this a little more
carefully uh so right here if you just
had this first term the bi then you
would get back what I showed you for the
probabilistic context free grammar so
this is just a parameter for each token
that says how probable is it it's like a
unigram probability um and then what you
can think about here is you have a sum
over the previous nword where you have a
representation for the previous word
this is V this is is a vector of length
D inter producted with these UI J um
vectors and so these are going to be uh
vectors of the same length D and the
inner product tells you something about
the compatibility of a word uh with an
output vocabulary word so there's
there's two different representations of
words here there's one the v's which are
the representation of input words and
the repes and then the U's which are
representations of output words both of
them are D dimensional vectors um and
then the score that you get in the
numerator of this probability term is
just a sum of inner products of the
output representation for the different
positions with the input representation
of the word that appeared in that
previous position there any questions at
this
point okay um I was gonna yeah I I'll
show you this just to well yeah I think
this is fine
um let's look a little more carefully
about where that yeah so when you're
doing these are there are you
abstracting the variable names of stuff
in some way or like when you say I is it
actually I or is it yeah uh I mean
literally sort of each distinct string
representation of a token is a different
word in the vocabulary
here
um right so we can look at this a little
bit more let's just look at what's
happening this is just to convince you
of what I said in the last slide um you
have these concatenated input word
vectors here and then you're going to
multiply this by a big Matrix U what you
can do is you can say I have a matrix
that's of size 1 by 3D where D is the
size of my representation you can break
apart this matrix
multiplication to be a sum of three
terms it's a sort of this is just the
formula for matrix
multiplication uh and then you can say
the I term is just by taking an
individual column of each of these U
matrices and so uh don't worry about the
details but this is just a sort of a
proof that what you get back at the end
is just this sum of input word
representations inner product with the
output word representation where you get
a different output word representation
uh for each position of the word that
you come
across um right and then the learning
problem which I won't talk about more is
going to be learn what these
representation vectors are and you can
follow all the standard stuff we heard
about yesterday uh to do
this okay um so the reason why I've gone
into all of this detail is now I want to
tweak it slightly um but the key point
to take away here is you have sort of an
input word representation and an output
word representation that changes based
on the position and then you're going to
take sums of inner products and that's
going to give you back these scores
which get turned into
probabilities so now let's look at these
loged by linear language models that
came up in machine learning natural
language processing so this is from
Andre Min and Jeff Finton in
2007 um and what they say is they kind
of do away with this neural network
interpretation but they just write down
what this score function is here so this
is a slightly different version of what
we saw before but it has the same
general flavor what you have now is you
just have one representation Vector for
each word the v's here um and then to
compute a score for output word I is
going to be the word representation for
word I inner product with the sum of the
word representations for all the
previous words that you've seen But now
what there is is there's these K
matrices which they call context
matrices which say you're going to
transform a word representation based on
a position dependent Matrix and so
there's a word representation in that's
shared across all of the previous words
but it's going to get trans formed by a
different Matrix based on which position
it appeared in okay and then you're
going to sum all these up you're going
to get a score
here um and then if you look at sort of
further papers along here there's little
tweaks that happen to this model um what
happens in this 2012 paper it's almost
the same form but now you have again a
different output representation for a
word as an input representation for a
word and these context matrices have
changed from being being full matrices
to just being diagonal matrices and so
you can think of that then as an
elementwise product of some context
Matrix which is just a diagonal matrix
um and then you get back something that
looks like this
um seeing a lot of like stairs
here yeah can you just clarify what the
output actually is yes um well so what
we're trying to always compute is this
probability of I and it's always going
to be defined in terms of this score
function which says in this case we're
just dealing with words so I is uh
indexing over words in your vocabulary
so what you're getting back is a
probability distribution over the words
in your
vocabulary it's saying that you're given
a a some previous words from um Jal 1 to
n these are your n previous words and
then what you're getting back is
probability distribution over what the
next word
is so how many outputs for the neural
net in this case um so the output is
going to be one of these probabilities
for each word in your
vocabulary okay so if in this case it
would be three or um no this this would
be uh so this is this is analogous to a
three G model so you're taking in the
three previous words but your vocabulary
size would be 100,000 or 200,000 and so
you would get back you you would take in
three elements of your vocabulary you
would output a distribution over 100,000
words that come next so the I is like
one of your output units so you'll have
so that f is just every single word in
your distribution you're outputting one
probability yeah yeah so so the f is
like
um uh what proportional to to to one of
the so the number of outputs of the
system is the size of your vocabulary
yes yes
yeah any other
questions um okay right and so then we
can look at results of how these things
work uh in just the text natural
language setting uh we heard about
perplexities before this is a measure of
um how uncertain the system is about
what words come next uh and what you see
here is there's these are sort of um
sort of strong engram baselines with the
kesser smoothing and you can see
basically that these log by linear
models the takeaway is is that you can
use a larger context size and so you can
go back 10 words here which you couldn't
do with an nram model uh and then you
get back uh per plexities that are much
lower than endr models and then you can
do other things like you can mix this
model with an endr model and you can get
back even better perplexities so this
this seems to be sort of a a strict
improvement over engram models at least
as far as I've seen the latest results
in the
literature um okay so then how do we
apply this idea to code and this is kind
of where I wanted to get at so let's go
back to having these history based
models and what we have now is we have
uh this dictionary of of of features and
values from the program that or from the
decisions that we've made so far in
generating one of these abstract syntax
trees now what we're
outputting just to be clear here is a
probability distribution over children
given a current so we're given a current
node R in the tree we're trying to
expand it and say let's give us a
distribution over the children so if
this is an internal node in the tree
then it might be sort of a list of
different node types um or list of
different sequences of node types and if
it was almost a leaf in a tree then it
would be a distribution over tokens in
here so you would have a very large
number of possible
children um and so the idea here is
we're going to have an output
representation for the parent to child
production we're going to have a input
representation for each value that
appears in our diary here and then we're
going to have a context Matrix or a
diagonal context Matrix for each key
that appears in this dictionary so what
you can see here is for example
different internal nodes will will
appear in different ancestry positions
inside history dictionaries at different
points in time what the values will
always get the same representation
across the positions but they'll be
modulated based on how far up in the
ancestry they appear and then the same
thing for the history in terms of tokens
that have generated been generated so
far so you have a sort of a subsumption
of an engram log by linear model here as
well by including these things in the
dictionary okay and then this follows
the same pattern where you get a
distribution over
children yeah number of children for a
given non-terminal is is defined by the
non-terminal because you're not
predicting the number of children here
anywhere right um the so the
distribution is over children
tupes um and
we um I mean if I could imagine for a
flat statement or whatever you could
have just a bunch of yeah so so what we
actually do here is we say that the
support of these distributions comes
from what we see in the training data
and then we have to what we're actually
going to do at the end of the day is
more complicated where we sort of
combine this model with the
probabilistic context fre grammar that
gives support to everything um so we
make sure we're sort of kosher but it
there's a lot of details
there in some cases you could have as
many children as you like it was a compo
statement yeah so you could imagine sort
of transforming the as a bit to say uh
if I have a block you know then I have
statement and next statement and it sort
of comes out into a fern or something I
mean I guess you could use this in a
more marized type fashion where you do
generate one child at a time yeah yeah
so so we've kind of used the as's Rel ly
unchanged in this work but there's
nothing specific to you could you could
apply some transformation to your ASDS
and then apply the model to the
transformed as is just
fine yeah and but sometime when you
generate one one next token in the estd
maybe it doesn't make sense uh
sure so this definitely will give
probability to some things that don't
make sense and that's just uh yeah it's
an imperfect model for sure
okay um I want to show you some results
here somebody asked earlier about how um
sort of neural models compare to engram
style models on code um so we took a the
caveat here is it's a relatively small
data set we just pulled it from online
it's about 140,000 lines of C code um
but so we've trained some NR models
these now are log probabilities so
higher is better apologies for switching
that up but um what you can see is
really the two G model does best the
three G model is about the same in terms
of the validation and test scores over
there for us a probabilistic context fre
grammar worked better than engram models
um our models for reasons I won't go
into we call LTT and this empty set just
means that our history dictionaries were
empty at every point in time and so then
it falls back to a probabilistic context
fre grammar get the same results here um
we also trained a log by linear engram
model of context length 10 the one that
worked best in the previous uh natural
language thing that I showed you and
this works better than the engram models
but not significantly better for our
results and then what we did is we said
okay let's add different types of
features into our history dictionaries
so features based on the hierarchy that
we've seen before so what's the parent
sequence of nodes uh that come above the
current node in the tree and then
there's also sequence-based features
which are sort of like engram based
features and so what we find is um the
sequence-based features are more
valuable than the hierarchy based
features but when we combine them we get
something that's better than
both yeah can you go back so here the
the
features I expect that you would have
many cases where you would have a
probability of zero of zero because it's
it's very specific you have many many
different features uh the features all
just get mapped to representation
vectors K could you repeat the question
oh sorry yeah the question was um if
features are infrequent will you get
zero probabilities
yeah um no so if we've never seen a
feature before we can just give it a a
representation Vector that's all zeros
and that will just not affect this F
score it won't zero out any
probabilities in terms of the output
distribution it will just say I won't
I'm not affecting the output
distribution you don't use any any PR
distribution transfer for the mass
transfer as as she just presented
yesterday uh no there's no sort of sorry
um okay you don't use any probability
transfer as Ashish was talking about
before so I think you're talking about
the smoothing in the engram based models
yeah so this is this is in the category
of the neural network based models and
so the smoothing is built in if I can
steal a phrase from
yesterday um okay let me just I'll I'll
I want to talk about one more little bit
and then I'll wrap up there um okay so
that's sort of a generic tree based
model and now I wanted to talk about
incorporating even more structure about
source code and this idea about
variables which are declared and then
they stay in scope for some amount of
time and then they go out of
scope um so what we do here is we say um
if you look at a tree that you've
generated so far Then There are rules in
the programming language that just tell
you when you've declared variables right
so we can recognize patterns or we can
just ask the compiler to do it for us so
that at any point in a program or any
point at which we've generated a partial
tree because we're generating sort of in
forward to back fashion modulo things
like
um if you declare instance variables in
a class below the current method that
you're trying to generate then we don't
we aren't capturing proper scoping rules
but for the most part we know when
variables are declared and what
variables are in scope at any point in
this process uh and so we'd like to use
that knowledge when defining this
probability over what we're going to see
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to maintain a extra set of
dictionaries um where each dictionary is
going to represent a variable and so the
variable is going to have features like
what is the name of the variable what is
the type of the variable uh when was the
variable last used how long ago was the
variable declared we can come up with a
lot of features of a variable for any
point in the program and so we're going
to have the set gamma uh that contains
dictionaries where each element of each
dictionary represents a different
variable um and now what we're going to
do is we're going to make a slight
modification to the abstract syntax
trees where instead of just having
identifier token nodes we're going to
have some that we call local and some
that we call Global the the global is
kind of our catch Shaw fallback for when
we we don't know what's going on the
local is we're going to generate an
identifier that we know is currently in
scope that comes from our from our
set so how are we going to do that well
I've already told you how to take a
dictionary and turn it into a
representation vector and we're going to
do the same thing so previously I told
you about this we have this history
dictionary where we have keys and values
and then we take the value
representations modulated by the context
representation for the key we're going
to do exactly the same thing but now for
keys and values in the variable
dictionary so we're going to have some
representation Vector for type int some
representation Vector for the identifier
name is I etc for all of that and then
uh we're going to combine those together
to get a representation for the variable
okay and then we're going to combine
that together in the same way as before
this this sort of used to be just a
representation Vector for the string I
or the token I but now it's going to be
composed of a sum of the component parts
of what's made up the dictionary and
then what we can do is we can say that
the probability comes from the score for
an individual dictionary here normalized
by the probability that uh we generated
any other variable from this
set
okay um right and then so how does this
work this turns out to give us a a
really big gain so this was what I
showed you before where we incorporated
the hierarchy and the sequence features
and this is where we now have this model
of scope I've additionally broken down
these log probabilities you can
attribute this sort of cost in log
probability uh to was it spent
generating a tree or was it spent was it
spent generating the internal nodes of
the tree or was it spent generating the
leaves corresponding the tokens and what
you see is that uh by incorporating the
scope model we actually pay a little bit
of additional cost in generating the
tree but we get a huge win in terms of
the cost of generating tokens um this is
kind of what you would expect and that
um you can imagine if you if you're if
you know what variables are in scope it
becomes much easier to generate variable
names inside your code model
um so just to show you samples from this
model of what it looks like um so what
we've done here is we've said okay
imagine in the previous line you
declared this array of strings called
words this gets put into scope and now
we'd like the model to generate four
Loops um and this gives you I think a
reasonable sense of what comes out of
this model um it's sort of on the
surface not bad but there's definitely
cases where it's generating meaningless
code you can see you know it's
generating I equals I there uh there are
certain things where the types don't
make sense um again it's doing words I
is equal to words I it's having this
meaningless statements and whatnot um
but syntactically it's actually quite
good um so relative to other things we
saw in the development of this string of
models this is this is sort of far
better than we've seen um okay so I
think I'll just wrap up there uh the
sort of the last point is just you can
adapt this to other settings and so
we've used this to build joint models of
natural language uh and source code
basically just by adding additional
features into the history dictionaries
uh and then other people like Charles
and them have used similar types of
models in this uh class name prediction
uh problem and so there's quite a lot of
flexibility here um so I
think maybe I'll just I'll just stop
there
yeah yeah please
um I don't yet completely understand how
many visible units and hidden units you
have
your hey Danny yeah how many hidden
invisible units are there in the model
keep raising the
hand um so the the picture to keep in
mind is something like this one if you
want to think of it as a neural network
it's you can but um and if you do think
of it as a neural network then it's just
a one hidden layer neural network so
there's this hidden layer which is like
the uh it's roughly going to be like a
sum of these different elements here and
then there's going to be an output
Matrix there um so it's roughly
something like a d dimensional hidden
layer an output that's the size of the
number of children children um that you
might see underneath the node in the
tree the input is a number of features
right the input here yeah there there'll
be sort of one block of inputs for each
uh key value pair in your
dictionary as far as by linear models
could you please comment on how good
they would actually operate on
predicting tokens that you haven't seen
in your
Corpus uh so right so the they they
don't do anything about predicting novel
tokens that you've seen before so uh one
of the details here is we assume that we
know what all of the tokens are in the
test Set uh up front for all of these
models so engram models have the same
issue if you want to do smoothing you
have to know what the set of possible
tokens are and so this is sort of an
assumption that unless you're doing
subword models of tokens you're not
going to have you're going to have to
make this
assumption and when you when you predict
new variables do you do you have like
just opaque name or you're actually
predicting from the space of new
variables you've ever seen
before um when we're like when you a
declaration or whatever where you don't
expect it to be scope yet for a variable
declaration we just predict the string
um so we just we just give it a name
there and then the L kicks in of you've
declared a variable with this
name I guess could you say a bit about
the model with the natural language
because that's that's cool
sure
um okay so I took a figure from Milto's
website he's quite good at doing this um
so for the natural language component
think exactly the same model but now
what we have is we have this additional
input which is something like a query
that somebody is issued on a search
engine so read file to string and then
our model is going to be of the same log
by linear form so s now I've changed
notation on you this is what F was
before um it's going to be composed of
basically four different terms so this B
should look familiar before this was
just the bias the the publ context
grammar term the r is the representation
of the children Tuple this again is the
same as before the C is again the same
as before a combination of the history
and the ancestry and whatnot and then
the new thing is we have this
representation of the natural language
and we want this to modulate the context
somehow so the model is this diamond is
either a addition or a multiplication um
it turns out there's reasons to prefer
the multiplication over the two as over
the addition there's you can see the
paper there's an example for something
you can do with multiplication that you
can't do with addition um and then right
then the basic idea was we went to stack
Overflow and we got a lot of examples of
natural language that came from the
titles of stack Overflow questions and
then code Snippets that came from
answers uh and then we trained one of
these models um so let's see the the
sort of the types of data sets we looked
at were again we just use C code um but
we have 30,000 questions and 40,000
Snippets in the answers and then what we
also did is we went to sort of being at
Microsoft we went to Bing and we found
search engine queries where people
clicked on a page that was uh one of the
stack Overflow questions with the
answers and so in this way we able to
associate search queries in natural
language with code Snippets and so we
have this data set with many more
natural language queries but the same uh
number of Snippets uh and then uh right
I don't have the results here but we
used these models after they were
trained up for both retrieving code
given natural language and retrieving
natural language given
code so in this case you use the same
model with the same training for both uh
applications so the question is use the
same model with the same training for
both applications and yeah um so we use
the sort of the noise contrast of
estimation stuff uh mentioned yesterday
and the the training is actually not
that hard sort of isn't any harder than
other log by linear
models yeah is that data set
available
um
no the so I think the Bing stuff will be
very hard to release uh I think the
titles and the questions of the stack
Overflow should be reasonable I think it
was relatively simple just searching
against the stack Overflow
dump yeah do you think is possible to
like incorporate uh character level
modeling to framewor or can we benefit
from that um yeah that's a good question
so can you incorporate character level
models
into into this framework um yeah I don't
see why not I mean um if you go
back sort
of what we're really doing is you can
think of this as some context
representation of what we have so far
and then this is a representation of
sort of the word or the token that
you're trying to generate it's just as
easy to think of this as sort of a
context input into some character level
recurrent neur networ and then uh sort
of nothing fundamental would change
about this framework
so can the model be used to like uh
capture for example World type the High
scho programs for
this can it be used sorry yeah can the
model be like used to capture the set of
world type the Haso program let's
say or yeah so can it be or Java
programs yeah or Java programs or C or
C++ yeah so I think it a really
interesting question is to what extent
can you guarantee that you're generating
valid programs um from these types of
models and I think you can get most of
the way there um there are a lot of edge
cases that concern me so this issue I
talked about before of how do you know
which variables are in scope well at
least in C when you have class
declarations you can declare variables
later down in the source file and they
will be in scope in inside a particular
method um and then there's questions of
if I start generating a method call uh
am I always going to be able to fill in
valid arguments or can I only generate
this method call uh given certain
conditions of the context so far and in
different languages I think these
concerns might be different so
uh I'm not sure to what extent it's
possible to generate all correct
programs with some probability and never
generate an incorrect program I think
that's a sort of a good challenge for
this line of work
though one in the back is it possible to
say one day like you know I can give you
a corpus of all programs that guaranteed
that do not the reference n pointers for
instance and then you learn and then you
train a model on that and then I use
that to as a as a now Checker um you
could try so the question is can you
give it a COR purpose of all programs
that do not reference no de reference no
pointers and use it as a checker I think
I mean this connects to a lot of
discussions we've heard about um you
know is is buggy code unnatural in some
way is kind of seems to me a rephrasing
of that question and so you know there's
probably some mileage to be had I
probably wouldn't do it that way if I
was really security concerned
but I have an inut like in our paper we
found um a security vulnerability using
as model so where the Norms were
whenever you are uh creating a directory
you are always checking directory
whether you have permission to create
the directory but uh so that is your
tring model right and when in One cases
they were missing that check we could
figure out that was a
SC
yeah take maybe one more
question so I have a question so in our
in my earlier study I saw I mean you
know the way software changes that is
also very
repeating so not only like writing the
same code so when when because we are in
a evolving software the way so I am
wondering whether we can uh predict a
model that how software
changes um yeah it's a good question so
the question is can you can you use
similar models for CH how software
changes rather than just generating from
scratch um yeah I think I mean again
sort of in principle I see no reason why
you couldn't do something like this so
you know you could imagine that your
sort of side input is not a natural
language specification but it's some
representation of the codebase that you
have already um I'm not sure exactly how
I would sort of generate where I'm
sticking in code but sort of in
principle you could say condition on
some code that I already have and now
generate some code sort of in context
based on that but I think the details
would take some work to to get
right great so I think we have a we have
a coffee break scheduled for now or
something so yeah so why don't let's
thank Danny
again